[MUSIC PLAYING]
NAOMI MAKOFSKY: My
name is Naomi Makofsky
and I'm on our Global
Product Partnerships team
here at Google.
And I focus on transactions
on actions on Google.
TARUN JAIN: And I'm Tarun.
I'm a PM on Assistant
and Actions on Google.
NAOMI MAKOFSKY: Now if you
think about your typical day,
it's probably full
of transactions.
You're buying coffee.
You're getting your groceries.
You're paying for dinner
with your family and friends.
And this week, we
spent a lot of time
talking about the shift
toward assistance,
and how actions on Google can
help users get things done.
So today, we're going to
dive into transactions
how users can buy physical
goods, services, and now
digital goods, from their
favorite brands, all of you,
through the assistant.
But before we jump
into what's new,
we're going to take a step back
to understand the big picture.
We're at an amazing
point in technology
where users are actually
turning to their devices
to get things done.
And we can help them accomplish
their goals across the widening
landscape of these devices.
They're turning to devices
in their, I want to know,
I want to go, I want
to do, see, hear,
understand moments, expecting
to get from point A to point B
or have a dinner
reservation booked for them.
But it's not just
their mobile device
that they're turning to
in these moments of need.
Users are turning to the
devices all around them.
As they have smart speakers,
smart cars, smart TVs,
refrigerators, ovens,
vacuums, this technology
is embedded in everyday devices
and it's more accessible
than it's ever been before.
And as we've discussed
throughout IO this week,
our approach at Google to
this era of digital assistance
is the Google Assistant.
So we're seeing a
few things happening.
So first, interactions
are more natural
than they've ever been before.
The experiences with our
devices are far from the call
center menus of the
past, or even the chat
bots of yesterday.
People are turning
to their devices
with queries that
are more natural.
And they're querying
beyond the keyword.
So they're asking
for things like, do
I need an umbrella today, as
opposed to weather, 10011.
Secondly, the platforms where
these digital systems live
have become mainstream.
And there's
increased familiarity
from the youngest
members of our households
all the way up to the oldest.
You can take my parents'
house for example,
where my 66-year-old father
cannot fall asleep without
the ocean sounds
from his Google Home.
And my mom's thrilled as
you can probably imagine.
But lastly, and
most importantly,
it comes down to our users.
Our users are more curious.
They're more demanding.
They're more impatient than
they've ever been before.
And they turn to their devices
in their moments of need.
So every time they want to
know something go somewhere,
do something, and so on.
And as a result of
their behavioral shift,
so too have their expectations.
Users want their experiences
on Google to be a few things.
They want it to
be more personal.
They want personalized
results just for them.
In fact, queries
that end in 'for me'
have increased over 60% in
the last two years alone.
They want their experiences
to be in real time.
From brands, they want real
time response to current events.
They want to be entertained.
They want to be consoled.
We see this on social
channels today.
As they shop, they
want immediate results.
They want to know it can be
delivered to them in just
a couple of days.
But more than that, they
want to know what's open now.
What can be delivered now.
What hotels they can
even book tonight
at a discount, of course.
And we've seen, in
fact, that same day
travel as an entire
category has increased
over 100% in the last two years.
But more than just
the what and the when,
it's really about the where.
Users want their brands to
be everywhere there are--
in their home, on their
phones, in the car,
everywhere they're going.
So as we've been developing
the Google Assistant,
we've thought a lot about
the when, the where and the
how users are already
interacting with Google.
So when they wake up,
they're asking Google Home
what their day looks like.
When they're on the go, they'll
turn to Google Maps for help
with driving directions
and navigation.
They're searching on Google.
They're watching
videos on YouTube.
They're playing games on
their Android devices.
There's already fluid
interaction across surfaces,
devices and properties.
And it spans from
information retrieval
to content consumption, all the
way through action completion.
So we've been diving
into these areas.
And we think about how actions
on the Google Assistant
can help a user
throughout their day.
How can we streamline
their morning?
How can we help the user do
more when they're on the go?
And, of course, how can they
have a relaxing evening at home
when the day is done?
The ability to transact
with your favorite brand
is key to task completion.
And this is crucial for any
platform to be truly assistive.
But more than that, the
user has to be able to do so
in an effortless way.
So before we dive into
the exciting updates
I know you're all
excited to hear,
we're going to talk a little bit
about the state of transactions
today.
Last year, on a stage
very similar to this,
we announced that transactional
capabilities were coming soon
to the Assistant via
our transactions API.
And just seven months
ago, we launched
basic transactional capabilities
via our transactions
API in the United States.
And now we're doing this
in even more countries.
We're live in the UK,
France, Germany, Canada,
Australia, and Japan.
And we're coming to more
countries over the course
of 2018 and beyond.
Now, when we talk about
transactions on the Actions
on Google Platform,
we're talking
about the ability for a
user to purchase a good,
hire a service,
book a reservation,
with their favorite
brand on the Assistant.
And now, no matter what type
of transactional experience
a developer builds, the
foundational elements
remain the same.
The developer will
always guide the user
throughout the purchase process.
And we have APIs and other
helpers, account linking
and location included,
to assist along the way.
So we're going to break this
down a little bit further.
No matter whether you're a
developer building a flow that
supports the purchase of coffee,
or the booking of a cycling
class, it will still boil down
to three transaction types.
First, there is a reservation
or appointment booking.
Now, this could
be free of charge
or have a cost associated
at the time of that booking.
The next two require payments.
So the developer could
support a transaction
via the user's payment
method that's already
on file with their business.
We call this Bringing
Your Own payment method.
Now, this of course,
requires account
linking, since you need to
know who that user is in order
to charge their card.
But the developer could also use
a payment helper from Google.
So if you want to support
a guest checkout flow,
this is an excellent way to get
that information from Google.
And we'll talk about
this one in a bit.
Let's start with transactions.
So it's a fairly simple flow.
You build the reservation.
You propose it to the user.
The user confirms.
And like any other
transaction on the Assistant,
you're able to send them
updates throughout the lifecycle
of the order, to make sure
that that booking is always
top of mind.
So it's been a great week at IO.
I've had maybe a few
more french fries
than I'm used to eating
in my typical week.
So I think I'm going to need
to book a spin class when
I get back to New York.
So let's consider
a quick example.
I tell the Assistant and I
talk to my favorite spin class
that I'd like to book a
class for Tuesday at 6 PM.
Jay's Cycle Spot will
then confirm this booking.
Sure, you want a
booking Tuesday at 6 PM?
I say yes, and my
booking is complete.
And then in the Assistant
app, I get updates
until that spin class to
tell me that this is still
in progress because I haven't
quite made it to that class
yet.
And I'm always reminded where
I'm going, what I've purchased,
and the stage of that order.
Now let's talk about a case
where a payment is required
at that point of booking.
Now remember, this
can mean you're
bringing your own
payment method,
or you're using
Google to help you
facilitate that transaction.
So first, you'll want to
check that a transaction is
enabled in the first place.
And we can also help you with
some other basic settings
and information to
assist along the way.
In fact, we have
an API where you
can check that transaction
settings are turned on,
so you don't get the user
throughout the flow only
to find out that
they can't transact.
If you're shipping
a good, you'll
probably need the
user's delivery address
so we can help with that too.
When a user sets
up the Assistant,
they choose the
information that they're
entering into the Assistant,
like payment information,
delivery addresses, and so on.
So should a user share
this information,
and should you need
it, we can help
by passing you this
information, of course
with the user's consent.
So if the user hasn't
already entered information,
like their delivery
address, we can also
help you by prompting
the user for the entry
and then resuming
the conversation.
So great.
We know the user
wants to transact.
So it's time to start
building that cart.
Our API has a taken
order object that's
flexible and easy to
adapt to your use case.
And our client libraries
contain builders
to help you build quickly
and validate along the way.
So you simply pass us
an order object that's
similar to what you
see here, and we'll
take care of presenting it
to the user in a way that's
clear and consistent,
so the user always
knows exactly what
they're buying
and how much they're
paying for it.
Now we know friction can lead to
some drop off in the conversion
funnel.
I'm sure a lot of you are
very familiar with this.
And we know that it's not just
about creating a seamless cart
building process,
but getting that user
through the point of transaction
as easily as possible.
So let's take a
look at what this
means when you bring
your own payment method,
or when you use Google Pay.
If you're bringing your
own payment method,
you're using credentials
that the user already
has on file with you.
And it will look
something like this.
And we accept a variety of types
from credit card, all the way
to cash on delivery.
It's really up to you.
And we use the
information that you
pass to us to let the
user know exactly how they
will be paying.
So here, you'll
notice that the users
is going to be paying by card.
And it's my gold
card to be exact.
This is the display
friendly name
that the user is able to
see that matches the payment
profile that they
have previously
set up with your company.
Now, if you choose to use a
payment helper from Google,
we'll just need a
bit more information
about your processor.
Users have already saved
hundreds of millions of cards
to their Google accounts.
And we can securely pass
this information to you
during an Assistant transaction
with the user's permission.
So you tell you Google
who you need to charge
and how much you need
to charge them for.
Google then encrypts
the raw credit card
with your payment
processor's key
to generate an encrypted
payment credential
and passes you that token.
You charge that
credential like you
would any other credit
card you have tokenized
on your app or your site.
And this is already part
of the Google Pay API.
It's the same data
that you provide
when you use Google Pay in
your Android app or site.
One API that works everywhere.
And Google Pay supports
the processors listed here.
And we'll have more coming
soon to the platform.
Now of course, a
transaction is not
complete at that
point of purchase.
There are updates
that the user will
find useful, and follow
on actions to help them
with next steps.
And with the
transactions API, you
can send updates to the user
throughout the lifecycle
of the order.
For example, you
can let them know
when the orders is received,
when it's being processed,
or even when it's complete.
Also, you can follow on actions.
So this enables the
user to do things
like modify their purchase,
place the reorder, contact you.
The user can seamlessly
take this quick action
for that action
post transaction.
TARUN JAIN: As you saw,
we made huge progress
on enabling transactions
under the Assistant platform
last year.
During this time, we
worked with a lot of you
guys, got your feedback, what
works, what does not work.
And that has really helped
us shape our roadmap.
So thank you so much for that.
Today we share a lot
more exciting updates
as we launch transaction on
more devices in more countries
and more Google platforms.
We also talk about supporting a
lot more complex transactions.
And then I'll end the talk
with my favorite topic,
on supporting digital
transactions on Assistant.
So app developers like yourself
can start monetizing Assistant.
Our growth on voice speakers
has been huge this year.
And it's only
continuing to grow.
As you saw through the keynote
and through all the I/O
sessions that we
have had so far,
it's a big focus area for us.
And we'll continue
investing in it.
So starting this week,
we are announcing
the support for users to be
able to transact over voice.
What that means
is, users can buy
physical goods,
physical services,
make reservations, on Google
Home, on third party speakers,
and even the SmartScreens
that are launching in July.
We talked a lot about
our vision and mission
to help users
accomplish their task.
We want to go
beyond where we just
connect the user with
a service provider,
but also help our users
accomplish their tasks in ways
that are safe, that are
convenient, and that are fast.
And throughout my session today,
and through some other demos
I'll do, you'll see
that theme resonating.
So we will keep
touching base on that.
Let's get back to
our user journeys.
You've seen this slide before.
And let's start with
the morning routine.
If you are anything like me,
nothing gets done in the day
before that first cup of coffee.
And most days a week, that is
my first transaction of the day.
So we'll show you how
Assistant can help solve
for simple but essential tasks.
So now the fun part,
which is the demos.
As I walk through
the few demos today,
I have picked up user tasks
that are everyday use.
You and me use that often, so
we can see the pain points.
But also visualize the
opportunities associated
with each of these flows.
The other thing I'll do is
after each of these demos,
I will pause.
I'll walk you through
how we build this,
because there's a lot to learn
from each of these demos.
Hey Google, order my
usual from Starbucks.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Hi, Tarun.
Starbucks here.
That's one tall soy latte.
Anything else?
TARUN JAIN: No.
That's all.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: And
are you picking that up
at your usual Starbucks?
TARUN JAIN: Yes.
That sounds good.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: OK.
That'll be $3.45.
But the balance on your
Starbucks card is only $1.04.
Do you want to reload your card?
TARUN JAIN: Yeah.
Put $20 on it.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: OK.
I've added $20 to your
Starbucks card with Google Pay.
Your total is $3.45.
Are you ready to
place the order?
TARUN JAIN: Yes.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: OK.
I put your order in and
it'll be ready soon.
Enjoy.
TARUN JAIN: Can't
wait to pick up
my coffee after this session.
So what you saw
here is something
that our users
will be able to do
fairly soon, starting in a
week or a few weeks from now.
There are two things that I want
to highlight from this demo.
The first thing is
personalization.
If you remember the experience,
Starbucks knows my name.
Greeted me by my name.
It even knew the drink
which is my usual drink.
You don't have to jump through
hoops our conversational turns
as we call it in our
world, to figure out
which coffee you want.
Starbucks even recommended
me a usual location,
based on what my
current location is,
where I've ordered in the past.
So you don't have to
have a conversation
to understand where you
want to pick up the coffee.
So don't you love a
barista who knows your name
and knows what drink
you want when you
walk into the local Starbucks?
Those are the kind
of experiences
we want to build on Assistant.
Personalization is very
important to drive user trust,
to drive user delight,
and loyalty on Assistant.
The second thing I will talk
about is the payment piece.
Now if you think
through the flow,
in the first couple
of conversations,
Starbucks knows
what coffee I want,
they know what location
I'm picking it up for at.
So for most users, that's it.
That's all the
information Starbucks
needs to have a great coffee
waiting for you when you
actually enter the Starbucks.
But I went through
a not so happy path
to highlight the point that
when it comes to payments,
when it comes to transactions,
seamless transactions are
important.
But equally important is
clear transparency to the user
on what they are
buying, how much
they are getting charged for,
and what does their transaction
look like.
So as we go through some
of these experiences,
you'll see that resonating.
So just to summarize, we
are opening up transactions
over voice this week.
The devices we support are
Google Home, the third party
speakers, and the smart
screens when they launch.
We are already live in the US.
And over the next week, we're
opening up UK, Canada, Germany,
France, Japan and Australia.
So you're thinking
as a developer,
what does it mean for me?
Do I have to start from scratch?
Do I have to build the
whole experience again?
What do the new APIs look like?
What is the cost of doing this?
And every time when I
launch a new service,
do I have to build
my actions again?
The short answer is no change.
If you already
had an action that
was using transactions
working on phones,
it will work out of the box for
the Google Home devices too.
For the SmartScreens
too when it launches.
So there is no work
needed on your side
to light up new surfaces.
We do the heavy
lifting to make sure it
works across all surfaces.
Sometimes as a
developer, you might
want to have a different
experience on voice
versus users on a screen.
And that's fine too.
You can actually build
those experiences.
We support it.
The underlying mechanisms of
transactions remains the same.
So that does not have to change.
So if you don't have an
app on Assistant yet,
you have double the reason
to go and build one.
Because you get
every new service
that will launch free with
any of these transactions.
The previous screen talked
about when you bring
your own transaction method.
But even if you use
Google Pay, there
is no incremental work
to kind of light up
the transaction on
the voice surfaces.
There are two other
things I'll talk about,
which I think were in the demo.
The first thing is
built-in intents.
We launched built-in intents.
This week.
What this means is, when a
user says, order me my coffee,
or get flowers for
Mother's Day-- by the way,
it's Mother's Day this weekend,
in case you dropped the ball.
But when you say get me
flowers or order me a coffee,
this is how
Assistant knows which
action can fulfill one intent.
That's what we use for
matching and ranking.
So as a developer, it's
very important for you
to sign up for
the right intents.
The second piece I'll highlight
is the conversation design.
Use dialogue flow to
create great conversations.
Stay succinct.
It is very important to
have your brand reflected
in the conversation.
Make sure you use
the brand tonality.
When you talk to your
users, without seeing you,
they should know that it
is your brand that they
are having a conversation with.
So now when we talked
about the building blocks,
I talked about
quite a few of them.
The one which is one of
the most important ones
is account linking.
And if a user starts on
phone, for the most part,
we would send user over-- if
the user starts on Google Home,
we will send the user over
to phone, to account link.
And the drop off percentage
is very, very high.
And no, we don't
like that number.
We have a 90% plus
drop off when we
point a user over from
a Google Home device
over to the phone to
do account linking.
So today, or this week, we are
starting a developer preview
for accounts linking over voice.
So what does that mean?
What that means is users
can sign into an existing
account using voice.
They don't have to be sent
over to a screen or a phone.
A user can create a full
new account all in itself,
over voice, without having
to go to any other surface.
And if a user is already signed
into an existing surface,
they will automatically
sign in when they come
to any of the voice devices.
Sounds magical, right?
So I'll talk about
how it works as well.
So the flow is fairly
straightforward.
You ask the user for sign in.
Their user gives their consent.
Once the consent is
there, we shared with you
a Google token which has a lot
of details about the users.
Think of it as the
user's Gmail address
and some additional information.
You look for that
user in your user db.
If you find that user,
you can link the account,
you can create the session, you
can create a token for the user
and send us their token.
And we will use that
token for future use.
If you do not find
that user, you
can create that user with the
information that we give you,
and send us a token.
So the 90% drop off
number that you saw here
can come down as low as 0 with
some of these experiences.
It's a straightforward
integration.
I think I'll walk you through
what some of the APIs look
like.
On the console, there
is a separate setting
that you have to sign up for.
Do you want OAuth, do
you want Google Sign-in?
You can choose both, depending
on different surfaces
and what experiences
you want to build for.
The sign-in API is
straightforward.
It speaks for itself.
Ask for sign-in.
So when you ask for
sign-in, we prompt the user
to go through the flow.
[INAUDIBLE] token I think
is the most important piece.
So when the user
grants the permission,
we share all of this information
about the user with you,
which includes an
email, which includes
is this a verified email or not.
We send you the
name, the given name,
the last name, and much more, so
that you can create an account
on your side if you want to.
Now that you are
really thinking,
voice and the beautiful
experiences voice
offers, let's talk through
some of the more things.
So here is the summary
of the building
blocks that are
talked about on how
to create a great
transactional experience.
Google Sign-In and the voice
experience we talked about.
Built-in intents.
That's how you identify and get
a lot more implicit traffic.
Personalization.
Needless to say, it's very
important to drive user trust.
Conversation designs.
And then the voice transactions.
And for the friends
who are visiting us
from all the different
parts of the world,
we are opening up over the next
few months in Mexico, Brazil,
Spain, Italy, and India too.
And our pace of
adding more markets
will only grow through
the last part of the year.
A lot of exciting stuff
happening on voice.
And I'm sure you
guys will want to see
what those APIs look like.
We'll share the link
toward the end of the talk
where you can go and see all
of this in a lot more detail.
But let's continue
our user journey.
So we talked about
the morning routine.
Let's talk about
users on the go.
You see, she already has
a coffee in her hand.
So let's talk about some
of the users on the go.
Well, users on the go, they
interact with many more Google
surfaces outside of Assistant.
They are on search.
They are on Google Maps.
And much more.
And we want to provide
a consistent experience
to our users when they move
from one surface to another.
Why should users experience be
painful on any Google surface,
right?
So we are bringing our
transaction primitives
across all Google surfaces.
When I talk about
transaction primitives,
I mean identity, which
is the Google Sign-in
piece we talked about, payments,
receipts, and a lot more
helpers, like delivery addresses
and locations and so on.
So these are now available
across multiple surfaces.
So let me show you guys
a quick demo on how
this works on search.
And we will go into a lot
more details with that.
So as I talked about
the essential tasks
when it talked about
the coffee, here
is another one of
the essential tasks,
which is getting movie tickets.
So movies near me.
Avengers, everyone
knows, is actually
breaking every possible
record out there.
They are doing fairly good.
Let me try to book
a movie ticket.
11 PM show after the
event sounds good.
Fandango.
They offer a fast check out.
Let me try that.
So the Fandango experience
on what we have built
is all on Amp.
And if you know of Amp,
Amp is all about how
to deliver content fast.
And now we're bringing
transactions into Amp.
What that means is even the
transactional experiences will
get very fast.
By the way, what I am
showing is all production.
It is not a hacked up demo.
So the speeds you will see
are very much what a user
sees when we take it live.
I can zoom out.
I can select two tickets.
Next.
The general admission
sounds good to me.
Next.
This is where we share the
payment information over.
As a user, you don't have to
give your payment information,
your email and so on.
Obviously, none of this
is shared with Fandango
until the transaction is done.
I look through the order.
Looks good.
Complete purchase.
And the transaction
goes through.
I have two tickets booked
for me for the evening.
[APPLAUSE]
And the other
thing with this is,
if you see at the
bottom of the screen,
there is my order's experience,
where I can go, I can find,
I can track, and I can
manage all of my orders.
So if I want to find where
there is a receipt for this,
I want to look for the tickets.
A single place where
any user can go and get
that information.
They can even ask Assistant
what time is the movie tonight
and Assistant would
answer it for them.
One more thing I
wanted to show here
was, a lot of you guys
might be Fandango VIP
exclusive customers.
Looks like I am not.
Let me try to sign up, because I
don't want to lose the points I
get on buying movie tickets.
I probably watch one
a week by the way.
This.
Share and sign in.
Looks good.
Verifying.
And this is account linking.
I have an account created
on Fandango's site.
It is linked to
my Google profile.
So next time when I go in and
try to get Fandango tickets,
I don't have to go
through this at all.
Its all linked through
my Google profile.
So that's the demo that
I had for Fandango.
And this is not just
for movie ticketing.
Our users can do so much
with these experiences,
coming in from search or
Maps or from other things.
The beauty is that users
get a fast checkout because
of these experiences.
These flows are what we
call convenience optimized.
Users almost never have
to fill out a form.
And I'll show you a much
more complicated experience
in a bit.
And there's a single
place for all our users
to track all their receipts.
So they don't have
to think through,
which merchant
did I buy it from?
What does the receipt look like?
Let me dig through my
email address and so on.
And from a merchant's
perspective, think of yourself.
You have full
control over the UI,
and therefore giving you
the ability to create
differentiated experiences
for your users.
So there's a customer
coming to your website,
there's a visitor that's
coming to your app experience.
You convert visitor to a
customer, to a loyal customer.
So I think that's one big value
brought by this experience.
You get much higher
conversion rates.
With Google Pay we
have partners who
have two times higher
conversion rates than what
they had earlier.
With Google Sign-In we have seen
conversion rates go up by 20%.
So that's a big lift for a lot
of our partners and developers.
And then merchants
spend less time planning
on the transaction
primitives, which
lets you focus on what makes
sense for your business.
And what I showed
with Fandango, you'll
see something like that
coming soon with AMC as well.
So we're going big
in movie ticketing.
One of my favorite activities.
But let's now talk about a
way more complex experience.
Doordash, which
is ordering food.
When you order food, food
ordering uses a lot of nuances.
There is massive menu browsing.
Like if you go to
a new restaurant,
menus these days are
like 10 pages long.
It takes you like 20 minutes to
see what all is being offered.
So there's a lot
of menu browsing.
On top of that, there's
a lot of customization.
You want to see, or as a user,
you want something gluten free.
I want extra spicy.
I want dressing on
the side and whatnot.
So after you actually have what
you want to order figured out,
then there is
delivery instructions.
I want it delivered
at this time.
I want it delivered in the
window of three to five.
Or delivering instructions,
like three knocks on the door
and you're going to leave
the food at the door
or something like that.
And then after that there is
the payment, the receipts,
the tip you want for
the Dasher and so on.
And then lastly, the
more important piece
is track your order.
Kid me not.
When you're hungry, you
want to know real time
where the Dasher is, right?
And you want that
experience to be fast.
And it should just
work out of the box.
So let's look like what the
Doordash experience looks like.
I'll show a quick video.
Here.
Order delivery from Cucina
Venti with DoorDash.
So this is the
Doordash experience.
It comes up on Assistant.
This is the menu browsing
piece I was talking about.
This is the customization.
All super fast,
built using Amp and
the transactional experiences.
Add to order.
No order is complete
without dessert,
so let's add a dessert too.
And they have good
desserts by the way.
They are around the street.
So check out the same thing.
There is a payment
already selected.
Delivery address is
already on the file.
And you can do the transaction.
Place order.
Order placed.
So a very, very seamless
experience for our users,
even without signing in.
They can actually
complete transactions
coming from multiple
different entry points.
So I think we talked
about food ordering.
And so on.
So let's talk about users' last
phase of the customer journey,
which is, have a
relaxing evening at home.
Today we are announcing
the developer preview
for digital goods.
What that means is,
our users can now
buy digital goods on Assistant.
We want to support this
on Assistant, on phones
and on voice devices.
When we launch this, this will
be across multiple markets.
US, UK, Canada, Australia,
France, Germany, and Japan,
the seven markets we
talked about earlier.
So it's been a tiring day and
a tiring week for all of us.
And when you go back to
your hotel or to your room
or to your house based
on where you are from,
you might want to
unwind and relax.
I prefer meditating.
So let me walk you
through an experience.
So this is a headspace.
This is a basic session, the
free package from Headspace.
You want to meditate
for a little bit.
10 minutes.
Two days in a row.
And that's all Headspace
offers for free.
So do you want to
subscribe to Headspace now?
Yes.
Makes sense.
Subscribe to Headspace.
The three products
Headspace offers
are a $12 monthly, a $95
annual, and a $400 lifetime.
I'm cheap.
So I'll stick with the
$12 monthly package.
Let me try that subscription.
Subscribe to the
$12 monthly package.
So here is a proposed order.
Remember, when we
talked about, you
have to highlight to the user,
what product they are buying,
what credit card is being used
and what the price point is?
You want to propose that to the
user before they say subscribe.
Our user says subscribe.
The transaction is done.
You are on your way.
The receipt is sent to you.
You have this
experience enabled.
Now the beauty of
this solution is
that users can consume
their digital goods
across Google surfaces.
If a user bought something
on their Android experience,
like the Headspace
Android app, they
can access their digital
good on Assistant.
And if a user buys something
using this on Assistant,
they are able to access the
same experience on Android too.
So from a user's
perspective, no matter
how they jump different
devices across Assistant,
across the Google surfaces--
the purchases they make,
the experiences they have,
seamlessly flow.
And from a developer's
perspective,
digital goods on Assistant is
an Assistant Play integration.
So if you already
are a developer who
sells digital
goods on Play, this
is a little bit of
incremental work
to light up transactions
on Assistant too,
or digital transaction
Assistant too.
You continue using
your Play Console.
You use your Play Console to
manage inventory and so on.
High level, the flow
looks something like this.
A user requests access
to a premium experience.
Or you can upsell a premium
experience to the user.
We check, does a user
have access to the SKU?
If yes, you can deliver a
premium experience to the user.
If not, you call
the Google APIs.
We tell you what
are the SKUs you
can sell to this user based
on any filtering criteria
that you might have.
You propose the order with
the product to the user.
The user confirms yes.
We process the transaction.
And we send you the purchase
token, saying, here is
the transaction confirmation.
Here's a purchase token.
And you will deliver the
premium experience from there
on to the user.
So this is a great
opportunity for our developers
to monetize, be it the
gaming space or premium
content and experiences.
So, for example, the
Headspace experience
was premium experiences.
You could have
premium content too.
In the gaming space,
a lot of you guys
might be aware of coins or
extra lives, extra turns, what
have not.
And I think whatever you can
sell from a gaming perspective
works beautifully
in this experience.
And also a la carte
digital media purchases,
like rentals and so on
are all digital goods
that you can start lighting
up with this experience
on Assistant.
So just to recap,
with digital goods
we are opening up the
ability to sell digital goods
on all Assistant surfaces.
This is in-app purchases
and subscriptions.
And we plan to light up
all Assistant surfaces
in all the markets that we
have transactions live in.
NAOMI MAKOFSKY: And
over the last few months
since we've launched,
so many great brands
have developed apps to reach
their users on the Assistant,
and enable that user to transact
with them wherever they are.
So you can buy your
pizza from Domino's, you
can order flowers for Mother's
Day from 1-800-Flowers.
And pretty soon
you'll be able to get
your favorite cup of Starbucks
coffee from the Assistant
as well.
And as we launch
these new features
and continuously develop
additional functionality,
we're so excited to see what
you develop for your users,
and what we can
all build together.
So thank you so much for joining
us on this third day of I/O.
And we hope to
see you next year.
[MUSIC PLAYING]